hallo mein name peter hettlich hier
kommen heute zu einem neuen video zu
staus die letzten drei tage haben kein
video auf einem kanal läuft kannst du
eigentlich kommt reiter konnte noch ein
video aufnehmen da ist mein handy kaputt
gegangen also der bio thema weil ich das
sinnvollste
aber am samstag blieben tag und jetzt am
montag wahrheit kommentare wahl in köln
und wir waren bayern und da bin ich
tatsächlich nicht dazu gekommen video
aufnehmen und kollege formieren haben
könnte mir liegen locker wenn du keine
video hochlädt abonnieren nicht mehr
leute wird bei alten job
aber es ist jetzt wirklich eingetreten
ich halt in den tagebausee 102000 1100
gemacht und dann abgefahren wo ich nicht
mehr hochgeladen haben die letzten drei
tage habe ich 3550 3407 3309 enten
gemacht obwohl ich mich irgendwie zeigte
dass wir vom bisschen dass die leute
nicht mehr abonnieren wenn ich nicht
hochladen das bietet feiern wenn ich
einfach nicht machen wenn ich meine
karriere beenden in der tat nachdem
chris tanner quasi prophezeit dass mehr
leute ein kanal abonnieren werden dann
in die hochlagen treten jetzt haben wir
heute mal gedacht dass chris einfach war
das nicht machen soll und dann abonniere
mich wieder ganz viele leute hinter der
kamera und bieten einfach verschiedene
sachen sagen die ich machen soll also
keine ahnung
du bist der youtube hochlädt
ja
in dem video aber erst mal das machen
muss erstmal die bakterien aber eine die
ich mir durch
damit weiter wenn die videobeweis wieder
mehr leute aber wir arbeiten daran dass
alle kapieren berechnen halten es für
fragwürdig aber erkläre dass er aber
jetzt waren vermutlich stück mit einer
hand um nicht schlafen wenn es mich
schlafen wenn man noch eine flasche und
war genauso wir überstehen
[Musik]
ja
die anderen preisträger machen kabarett
mit zwei mal im kreis werden jetzt noch
einmal das könnte bald allen leuten
nicht abonnieren wollen weil er hat mir
das jetzt nicht mehr leute sagt
geschrieben
black einmal in der wand
juli geschnürt bekommen und eine minute
lagen die kadetten auf deutsch rapper
unterlag herum mit karneval
[Musik]
er war die letzten tag unterwegs keinen
wenn diese entsteht unterwegs war nicht
mehr unterwegs denn wir brauchen bürger
für dumm weltcup-comeback platzbedarf
dass wir euch spielen wir danken dir mit
viel wasser weg länderspiel in köln aber
nicht an mir
denn das ist zu weit weg an münchen
fliegen je mehr leute da hat meine damen
und herren club hat auf jeden fall
vorher gesagt was wenn wir dieses video
hier hochladen das mich dann sehr viele
leute an ihren werden also abonniert mit
ihr habt ihr im fall die 100 wenn er
darauf ihr könnt ihr nicht abonnieren zu
dürfen und lassen und bei 5000
[Musik]